dans la plupart des métiers les débuts
sont difficiles mais c'est vrai sans
doute plus qu'ailleurs dans le monde
très fermé de la mode pendant que les
stars de la couture présentée ces
derniers jours leurs modèles de
printemps au salon des créateurs dans le
jardin des tuileries
des dizaines de jeunes stylistes
essayait eux aussi de se faire connaître
avec des moyens de fortune
emilie raffoul a suivi le parcours et
partager les angoisses de deux d'entre
eux rien ne dit que ça n'arrivera pas
bientôt mais pour l'instant le succès il
se le joue dans l'intimité
c'est le lot de tous les petits jeunes
qui se lancent et tandis que les grandes
maisons font travailler les usines
raphaël et pascal jouent aux fourmis
c'est leur première collection d'été
étaient 86 l'emprunt aux banques a
acheté les tissus les copains ont fait
le reste et le tout se passe dans leur
appartement conception couture et vente
je travaille en parallèle on cherche pas
des grosses des fusions parce qu'on n'a
pas la possibilité aujourd'hui on
travaille vraiment
une échelle artisanale bon nos produits
se veulent de haute gamme aussi donc ça
se répercute aussi sur la quantité et
donc on préfère travailler comme ça en
fait c'est plus humain pour nous et puis
c c'est dans nos moyens aujourd'hui
deux mois plus tard c'est l'essayage les
modèles sont terminées et c'est une amie
mannequin débutante qui viendra pour les
dernières retouches afin de trouver chez
d autres qu un moment aujourd'hui créée
pour soi je crois que c'est ça on a
envie de se réaliser soi même de vendre
nos propres produits vous de démarrer à
partir d'un dessin et puis de voir nos
produits dans une boutique mais je crois
que c'est la récompense qu'on peut
attendre de nous et quand on démarre
comme ça comment on fait pour se faire
remarquer bon on fait du bruit on essaye
de sortir la tête
dans la foule on essaye de faire coucou
on est là on existe on essaie d'être
original on essaye de chez pas bien
chaud bouchet on essaye aussi de passer
15 heures à travailler à trouver des
solutions
resté 15 heures avec des vêtements on
trouve toujours une solution
il ya quelques jours enfin la dernière
étape ou plus exactement l'examen un
mini défilé organisé dans un hôtel
parisien
aujourd'hui c'est la quête des clients
qui commence avec un sigle à faire
connaître rubis d'auzat c'était le nom
d'un dandy au début du siècle à monsieur
qui lui réussissait auprès des femmes